whenever I hear stuff like this like
when people are like you know oh you
know money doesn't make you that happy
or like you know after this amount
doesn't really do anything for you it's
like yeah you're probably right but I'm
just G to check yeah I would like to
find out I'd like to find out I'm I'm
gonna go ahead and test for myself
[Music]
yeah all right we're live um can I start
the podcast doing something that you're
going to dislike can I complain I want
to complain oh everybody wants that I'm
having a really shitty week and I'm
having a horrible day so basically like
uh personal life there's some stuff like
we thought the pregnancy was going to be
one day or the due date was going to be
one day now it might be another day I
don't have the supplies I need so I got
to go and buy the crap this weekend that
I think I need I'm really stressed about
that at Hampton we uh are dealing with
like we're having to make like uh
policies that I've not used to having to
make like maternity leave and things
like that so those conversations are
exhausting to me and then um I got sick
this week and I took this medicine that
made me bloated I don't know if you
could tell by my face but I've gained 15
pounds in the last three days I feel
like you need to poke me with like a
needle and I need to like let out air I
feel miserable my all my fitness gains
that I've made in 3 years it feels
completely erased rank those from worst
to least worst the bloat is the number
one worst right it has to be but listen
I have a worst thing listen to this
you'll find this hilarious I did David
Pell's podcast he asked me to look at
his edits I log in let me read to you
the first edit that he made to his
editor that I read it he said this is a
note from David he goes hey can you
remove the I love Nazis part it's a
little distracting clean it up
basically on the podcast he was like
what do you like to read lately I was
like oh you know I've been loving like
history I've been loving War War uh in
particular I love Nazis like I like
reading about
that and I just log in and I'm like
remove the I love Nazis part and so
anyway I've had a hell of a day dude I
feel bad and it's like 11: a.m. am I
being am I soft right now or is or
should we just pull the plug on on
everything millionaire has uh gas or
whatever by the way really funny we uh
we were at a dinner uh with these guys
who like these other founder investor
type guys and then somebody was like oh
do you want this and Ben goes no I'm
okay they're like what you don't like
this he goes no I just I feel bloated
and then the whole table turned and
looked at him and were
like are you a pregnant woman why are
you saying you feel bloated and I was
like I never heard a guy say I feel
bloated I'm not saying it doesn't happen
but I am saying you should never say it
it's
just it's the what what was your list of
like drinking from a straw holding yeah
men don't drink from straws don't
hold saying bloated is is now on that
official list of of never do it it makes
you look super soft men do not drink
from straws men should never hold mugs
or cups with two hands that's a rule you
don't do that another rule that I'm
thinking about making is if you get a
drink and there's a lid on it you always
take the lid off
and and for sure for sure men do not say
bloated uh yeah we could add that to the
list added to the list all right good
good we got that settled um okay so
besides your your petty complaints um
where do you want to start what do you
got so you have Facebook are you talking
about the uh Lex Mark interview Mark
yeah so I see this thing so so Lex
Freeman does this interview with Mark
Zuckerberg and here's the setup about it
like I don't know when Facebook
rebranded to meta but I think it was
like two years ago uh or a year and a
half ago and um Chang the name meta
people are like okay why and he's like
because the metaverse and the metaverse
might be get on that bloated list as
like words you should just never say
it's like if I was like hey guys I'm
logging into the information Super
Highway real quick it's like you know
how they used to call the internet that
like back in the 9s that's what they
called the internet so so you know the
metaverse was always this dorky thing
and you know the problem with it was
like people were like oh okay it must be
it's is it awesome is there something
awesome I don't know about and then
they're like so what what is it Mark and
he's likewell it's um digital identities
and avatars and and they're like oh
we're laring now we're not what are we
talking about here and so then the demo
so Ari can you pull this up pull up the
initial demo where he was like the
future of work check it out Facebook
Horizons whatever and he pulls up this
that's
me this goofy Avatar of Sam
par if you're on YouTube right now so
it's this absolute cartoon like The Sims
version of Mark Zuckerberg standing in
front of a tiny Eiffel Tower which makes
no sense and they were like yeah like
you don't need to do business meetings
on Zoom anymore you could do this and
everyone's like I'll never do that and
so you know it's Facebook meta stock
price tanks people are like he's wasting
all this money on the metaverse he's uh
you know this guy's clueless and stock
tanks but I I was believed as you know
we are we are pro Zuck on this podcast
hard to bet he's hard to bet against so
bet against I start buying the stock I'm
like I'm like that guy who liked the
GameStop you know stock and he's I like
the stock I like the stock by the way
did you see the movie that came out or
the show that came out about that on
Netflix I'm gonna watch it yeah I'm
watching it for sure it's it's pretty
good I would say I give it like a it's a
solid B+ it's like a for guys it's
entertaining we're gonna we're going to
make that the official rating of dab
we're going to call it dab DEC at best
that's our new rating it's dab how is
that it's dab yes exactly so so anyways
um we like the stock we buy it because
we believe that this guy is not going to
go all in and lose now fast forward
about a year in one year here's what the
metaverse looks like now he goes on Lex
Freedom's podcast it looks like him and
Lex are talking to each other but
they're actually whatever thousands of
miles apart doing this podcast they're
wearing the new like Quest device or
whatever and check this out so this is
unbelievably realistic like it looks
identical to their face um the freckles
on their nose the lighting the the the
mouth movements while they're talking
like it's super super realistic which is
funny cuz like both of these guys barely
move their mouth actually so it actually
looks a little stiff but it's because
Lex Freedman and Mark Zuckerberg areff
the stiffest guys on the planet so you
know the guys who like don't show
emotion so it wasn't really that good of
a demo in that sense but kind of amazing
now it had like a black backdrop like
there was no they don't have the
background stuff built yet but yeah so
explain how that works so basically what
I'm seeing is Lex and Mark are wearing
what looks like an Oculus but slightly
different but basically an Oculus and
then are there cameras outside of the
that's it wow that's it so they're
wearing this headset and what what
happened is they both did this scanning
process so right now it's not like the
sustainable thing but like that that
purple image is the 3D codec scan
basically so they went and got this like
scan done which today like kind of the
manual process to do this but in the
future the device itself or your phone
will be able to do this scan for you
you'll just it's like a Xbox has a thing
called connect I think it works the same
way where it's basically like you stand
in front of it one time you look to the
left you look to the right you look up
you say these 10 sentences you move your
hands around and it's like cool I've now
recreated you perfectly digitally from
now on um and by the way this is going
to be like the DMV also because what
ends up happening is whatever you look
look like when you got scanned that's
you online now and so like I could be
sitting there hair disheveled having
shower beard on my face but if my avatar
is When I Look to my best that's how
everybody will see me in my meetings and
on the podcast or whatever it's like
when you die and go to heaven what do
you imagine someone to look like you
know like which a which age are they for
eternity that's sort of like this you
know what I mean I feel like it should
be like whatever you remember them by
that's what you see and so you know that
that that be that'd be my My Hope but
they so right now they're doing this 3D
scan they create this Advanced model
that's the thing like why is this not
release to everybody because they have
to figure out how to do that scan just
like on a phone uh so that anybody could
do it but after that the thing was
incredible and I just think the progress
in one year from that cartoon that's
awesome Cartoon Avatar in front of the
Eiffel Tower to this is unbelievable and
now this when you see this you're like
oh okay I kind of get this metaverse
thing like uh this is cool like they
were hanging out in a room they could
play ping pong together they could do an
interview together without ever having
to travel without ever having to leave
their space that is pretty impressive
dude what do you think about Mark
Zuckerberg's patience when everyone was
like nerd like what are you doing dude
this is the stupidest thing ever and
like he knew how amazing this was going
to be dude I just imagine like the
Arthur fist he just like clenches his
Arthur Fist and that's his only like
Outlet of emotion and he's like continue
nothing nothing he just has he he just
like walks around with a notebook and
like he'll just like cross a name off a
list every once in a while of like
Revenge got
him or you'll just see someone like high
school Crush that it's the Winkle boss
Twins and now the list is just super
long like someone will like insult him
in an interview like hold that thought
and pull up his notebook and just you
see him not and put Sean with two A's or
okay no no no Mark I like the stock I
like the
stock dude he's totally pulled us off we
always have said this but imagine this
like a guy who's been the top of the
game since he was 20 years old married
to the same woman the entire time has a
happy family has Hobbies has never had a
major scandal at least nothing involving
his personality super ripped uh don't
forget super ripped fit seems pretty
nice this guy's awesome man by the way
you just described LeBron James also
exact exact description of LeBron James
also they are the same they both were
big shots at the age of 20 they're both
ripped to certain degrees or different
degrees um they both have never had
major is LeBron LeBron's been with us
his like high school girlfriend forever
right they're married Savannah yeah and
and he has a bunch of kids uh and like
family it seems like I saw LeBron at the
wi Casino one time and I was like LeBron
and then I go up to him and I try to DAP
him up and like his security was they
were there but like he was walking so it
was like I wasn't bothering I was it was
clear I was being quick I got off the
blackjack table to just do it and uh
when I tell you that my hand was a tiny
Pebble in this man's giant hand I have
never felt
so honestly so supported I felt so like
taken care of when I just put my hand in
this guy's giant mitt it was
unbelievable to see a human hand just
wrap my my whole hand up yeah women
aren't the only people who like to be
hugged and like everybody needs a Big's
food and I found mine it's LeBron
James all right have you heard dude wait
have you seen this thing Zozo fit z z fi
T oh was this the like motion capture
thing it's it's a it's a suit this guy
in J Japan came out with this thing I've
been like paying attention to this for
10 years it has never lived up to its
hype I've been about this forever but
it's a suit that they sent to you it's a
bodysuit you put it on and they claim
that it like knows all the dimensions of
your body and then you could buy
clothing that like fits perfect to it it
doesn't work things that Sam's been
telling me about for seven years denim
Brad Adcock and
zozofit I love Zozo fit man I've wanted
it to work because I've got huge thighs
and a fat ass and so finding pants
finding pants for me weirds but okay
it's just it is what it is just well
explain this guy so this guy is a
Japanese billionaire right like he's
like a he's a Japanese billionaire he
came up with like a media company that's
originally I think how I found him I
think it was the media company and then
his new thing was he's going to start
this clothing company and he's going to
mail everyone a Zozo suit for free per
fit right the perfect fitting clothing
turns out I think the clothing company
like didn't even do that well but people
are like yeah can I just get this Zozo
fit thing and just use it for everything
also to like tell me if my muscles are
getting bigger or if I'm losing weight
like tell me about it all and so he just
says all right fine it's a 50 bucks like
it's going to be really cheap and you
use your phone it's like um when you see
like the Lord of the Rings movies being
made and they're wearing these weird
suits with these balls on them it's
basically that it's a suit like that way
and you like somebody should be making
this for with just AI now so um you know
like calorie counting apps have been
around forever yeah and you used to have
to manual you know you'd be like okay
it's lunch and you'd open My Fitness Pal
or whatever and you'd be like I've been
using my fitness pal every day for years
and you would um you'd be like yeah I
had a chicken salad they're like how
many ounces of chickens like I don't
know dude I didn't weigh it uh 8 ounces
they're like cool like light dressing or
medium it's like I don't know sounds
like a personal question what are you
asking me about like and so you you had
to manually input all this well now
there's these apps like Snap calorie and
stuff like that you just take a picture
of the thing and it's like good enough
now where it can actually guess the
calories um and and I I would say like
it's still not all the way there because
it doesn't know let's say like how much
oil was used in cooking this for example
but that we're getting to that point
where you can just take a picture and it
knows the calorie count well I think
we're also going to get to the point
where if I'm on some Ecom site and I'm
like am I a large or a medium I don't
really know I'm going to be able to
click a button it's going to turn turn
on my camera and it's just going to scan
my body and be like you're an extra
large I hate to break it to you and like
you know that's what's gonna happen here
you're 61 like 200 pounds you don't wear
mediums in the metaverse occup be any
size I want Sam all right I might be a
small to medium I may be a medium um but
you get what I'm saying like I think
that this is all going to become like oh
your phone can just do that now you
don't need to wear this haptic bodysuit
from zozofit like that's where this is
definitely going if I was like a really
smart team that was like good with like
computer vision and that sort of thing I
would do something like this because it
might not even work for the first year
but like two years from now it should be
able to work really well and then that
is a thing you could sell to every Ecom
site in the world because every Ecom
site wants lower returns every every
apparel every fashion brand wants lower
Returns the way they can do that is by
getting the perfect fit for people
what's uh do you want to talk about
rewind or the CL clavio thing yeah one
last thing on the Facebook thing I think
but here's my random prediction in 10 to
15 years Facebook is going to be
Facebook the like meta is going to own
the largest work platform so I think
that they're going to be the the zoom
the whatever because this experience
where it looks like you could feel like
you're in the same room as a person and
you can pull up you know PowerPoints
together you can do all that stuff
without like video conferencing I think
that's uh whoever does that right is
going to take over the the the work
called
space and I don't see who could do it
better than Facebook at this point
because they have such a lead as far as
the tech goes so I think we'll look back
we'll tell our kids yeah Facebook back
in the day used to be about sharing uh
you know photos of your of yourself at
parties from college and they'll be like
what the thing I use for work every day
it's like yeah that's that's the
difference I think 10 years it's going
to be like that I have some cash sitting
sitting around that I was going to use
to pay taxes should I just uh hold that
for you yeah should should should beg
Zuckerberg uh uh keep an eye on my money
for me exactly you're holding his money
uh all right so now rewind so did you
see this uh thing that came out it was
pretty
controversial the there's a guy or
there's two companies I came out with
this at the same day which is uh we'll
just say rewind because that's like the
one I remember the name of um it's this
pendant you wear so it's like a necklace
um it's like you know the Angelina Jolie
necklace where that she like was wearing
the blood of like a a small child in
Africa or something yeah I don't know
what was going on but like it was it was
worse it was Billy Bob th it was what
what's like the blood is the blood of
Billy Bob Thorton just like motor
oil just sweat so so there's this
pendant that you wear now that basically
I don't know if you saw this but it can
while you're wearing it's just going to
record everything everything you say
everything that's said to you it's going
to automatically transcribe that and
then save it locally on your phone so
that if you're ever wondering like what
did that person say or what did my wife
asked for groceries or did that person
incriminate themselves you can now have
that all transcribed and stored for you
on your phone and some people are like
did that guy reveal where the bodies are
or
not we found out if Adan s killed that
girl or not you know he he wore the
rewind pendant he was an early adopter
so there's this so a bunch of people
were dunking on him on Twitter I think
he tweeted out like I don't know 1,700
people bought the thing on day one which
is not that much like it's like you know
maybe that's uh what is it 1,700 it's
like 60 bucks uh a thing 100 Grand of
Revenue on day one not that good they
one of his thing not that good um and
people the tweet that went viral was
like oh so we're just gonna we're just
going to be wearing a wire now like
that's what's up just going to walk
around we're going to voluntarily just
wear wire
great tweet I got to say at the same
time the answer is yeah yeah you know
what you also carry around a GPS tracker
with your location at all times that
also has a microphone on it you know
what you also do you have a a camera
device on you when you're in the
bathroom taking a [__] or taking a
shower like we already have given up
privacy everywhere and uh the the the
the line I used in my newsletter I was
like um you know privacy is like
vegetables and we give it up we we'll
happily give it up for just the promise
of a moment of pleasure or convenience
well that because because that's the
junk food and like we just go for the
junk food that's the reality of the
situation is very few people will opt
for vegetables when they have the option
for junk food and if this is Tech that
can either save you time give you
entertainment uh you know like allow you
to to be lazier in some way people are
going to do that I remember my family
like I had some family members that were
like oh this vaccine is just for Bill
Gates to track US and I'm like hey Uncle
Ron listen he already tracks you like he
already knows I track you with find my I
find my friends I know where you went
all day today you shared your you shared
your location with me like he yeah like
remember that 23 me thing where we send
in our blood like it's already being
tracked okay like you're already Bill Mr
Gates already has everything he needs so
he doesn't need to do this um Hey Ron
you deleted your cookies anytime
recently yeah forgot to delete my
cookies yeah so like Bill Gates he has
what he needs uh I will not be wearing
this thing rewind I don't wear any
wearables because I don't want to be I
want to be tracked less and this [__]
just stresses me out that's surprising
to me because I feel like you've done
all of the like blood testing age
testing inject inject random chemicals
that some dude on Reddit said uh you
know helped him feel stronger inject
that in your butt like on on one hand
you're willing I'm drug free at the
moment well at the moment is the key
phrase there so by the way it feels way
less
good by the way hate
it yeah it sucks why are you resistant
to some of these trackers but then on
other in other cases you're very into
measurement and whatnot uh one I am kind
of like going to the like more pure
where it's like less is more I don't
want I don't want drugs I don't want my
cell phone I like when I go out most of
the times I don't bring a phone um so I
don't like having my phone on me yeah
like when I go out I won't bring a phone
I have a Tesla so I could use the
directions on my uh on my car and so
like if I go like I went have to eat
last night I don't bring a phone what is
that weird yeah that's very weird I I
don't I I won't bring it so I I just
don't bring what happens if you need to
text someone or what happens if somebody
calls you what happens if uh you get
bored for three seconds and you need
entertainment what do you do yeah I I
don't I I I just don't bring a phone
most places I don't bring a phone so
like if I'm going out on the day for the
day on Saturday I won't have up my phone
with me um okay Mr I'm better than
everybody so you're saying about mental
illness what were you saying no I uh
yeah so I I just I've gone from like so
I used to have a whoop I had an Apple
Watch I the only trackable thing I use
is eight sleep and I only use that
because it makes my bed cold but I don't
even like track any of that so I don't
track anything I do do the blood work
stuff because that's just a fun hobby
but uh uh I don't yeah my hobby is like
pain I like getting poent needles um but
yeah I don't do any of that stuff do you
track yourself like do you I I I like
whoop I just don't want to track any of
that [__] I don't care I'm not I'm not a
huge tracker I actually just bought this
Ur ring because I uh I wanted to test my
before getting the the surgery for my
devv septum and after I wanted to see if
my sleep improved or not but normally
I'm not a big tracker but yeah I do take
my phone please uh yeah no I don't track
any of that stuff so I'm not going to be
buying this thing are you
um I'm not going to buy this thing but I
do if again it's sort of inevitable like
I think if you just track forward in the
future we're gonna have de we're going
to wear a device on us that's a camera
and a uh and a microphone and we're just
gonna like which actually brings me to
the second Facebook announcement did you
see the glasses that they that they had
the the new Rayband
things so I had V1 of this and I've had
the spectacles I've had this none of
them have quite stuck yet but it is kind
of amazing it is kind of amazing the
demo is really cool he's like watch this
like I can basically live stream you
know just handsfree like if I'm at
something cool or whatever I want to
share this on my Instagram or share this
with my friends I can just uh push this
button on my glasses and it's a camera
that's going to capture this or if I'm
at the park like this is a big one for
me I'm at the park with my kids there's
so many of these Great Moments and just
literally it sounds stupid it sounds
like Petty but like the time it takes to
like get your phone out of your pocket
unlock your phone get to the camera app
and do it the moment is gone and so um I
had these things that the these rayb
bands that Facebook made that like you
know while I'm working out or while I'm
with my kids at the park or whatever I
can just quickly just like record
anything on the flly and it just grabs
the next 15 seconds it saves it to my
phone personally and then if I wanted to
share that I could um and the video
turns out really cool it's like first
person view so I definitely am excited
about this I think this is another like
one of these breakthroughs I'm waiting
for I'm actually less interested in the
like glasses that like show your email
to your eyeballs I don't really care so
much about that but a camera that's an
always on camera um I think is really
cool to be able to share Cool moments of
course there's like the privacy concerns
or whatever but I think it's going to
happen and uh is it weird that I I trust
I kind of trust Facebook privacy wise is
that do you well you know what it is
it's kind of like that family member
that like actually has like you know
they've done some [__] but they're like
I've known them for 32 years now like
you know like I guess I just kind of
default to them you know like at the end
of the day if I'm leaving my keys with
somebody it's the one I've known for 30
years versus you know even though they
they've gotten into some some sticky
spots but like I feel like it's a known
Evil versus an unknown evil in that
sense yeah I kind of trust him for some
reason I I definitely trust them um by
the way people in the comments going to
hate this because there's still a huge
population of people that are like hate
Zuck hate Facebook and hate that we we
love we we say we trust Facebook that's
like Blasphemous to a lot of people
anyways let's move on I don't care all
right listen so uh here let me tell let
me bring up this topic and I want to
hear about your experience with this so
two companies went public in the last
couple weeks you probably big fans of
both of them I think you're more fans of
one of them what's it called clavio
clavio clavio yeah I how you say it I
call it clavio I think it's clavio so
clavio it's sort of like uh it does
everything it's email software but
mostly for Shopify folks right
e-commerce yeah so if you want to send
emails you know oh you know your order
is confirmed or or things like after
somebody comes to my site and I grab
their email address email them every day
until they purchase for the rest of
their life you know that sort of thing
so they went public let me see what
their market cap is today they went
public right now their market cap is
eight or n billion the founder when it
went public he owned roughly 40% of the
company still wow which is amazing um
another company went public this guy um
started what's the guy's name started
instacart you know I bet you've had run
with Indian guy Aura I think he uh seems
like a great guy went public he only
owned 10% about about of the business um
and what's crazy is I tell people that I
tell people that your cap table I think
is the one thing in your company that is
irreversible for mistakes besides that
most every mistake that you make most
mistakes at all most mistakes you can
reverse or you can fix cap table the one
thing you can't fix and what's crazy is
when I was starting um a few of my
companies I remember like wanting to
raise money and I'm like oh what's 10%
here what's 10% there I'll just make my
employee pool you know what most people
only make it 10% we're going to make it
18% we're going to go big if we if I if
the company succeeds everyone should
succeed like I would do these like I was
really Loosey Goosey with equity and
that's one of those things now where I
look at people it's like when people
tell me like oh you got to sign this NDA
before I tell you my idea it's like oh
that's silly I'm not that that just
shows me proof you don't know what
you're doing right but with with Equity
it's actually one of the very few things
that's really really important
and so the difference between these two
um these two cap tables the difference
between 10% and 40% we're talking like5
billion um which is just a huge I don't
know if it like how much of that is it's
a mistake versus one is a capital
intensive startup and one is software
that's not as capital intensive well
both I think both so instacart is I
guess that would be Capital intensive
maybe I actually don't know where that
would be maybe maybe Middle Ground of
capital intensive whereas clavio you
actually could argue it's also middle
because you have to hire lots of
Engineers but maybe not um but my point
being is I actually think that people
are too willy-nilly with their Equity
early on right and I made that mistake
at my first company uh and it's a
horrible horrible mistake one that you
cannot recover from and there's so many
examples I know a guy who sold this
company for three billion or sorry for
$1 billion he sold it for $99 $980
million he made3 million bucks from it
um I swear to God it was because he's
like we had four co-founders we got we
raised a lot of money I gave so much
Equity to employees it was insane he's
like I lost my share certificates I just
don't know where to put them
like what's happening how's that
possible um have you heard the story of
how uh instacart got into YC no oh is
that where they went and bought
literally every grocery ever at Trader
Joe's no I think that might be a
different story that's also probably a
good one but basically the story is like
they uh I think they were exp like they
were trying to apply late and um and
basically they were like you know we
they they were trying to get
introduction all the YC Partners were
like no sorry it's too late to to get
this batch you get to the next one um
Gary tan who's now the current president
of YC was like you know you could submit
a late application but it'll be nearly
impossible to get you in and they're
like so you're saying there's a chance
like they they read nearly impossible as
possible yeah right because technically
it's true and um then they put together
the application they get the reply the
next day no and so they get rejected
he's like okay um he's like how about
this and so he goes he opens up his the
instacart app and he buys a six a
sixpack of beer and he put sends it to
the uh YC headquarters for Gary tan and
um he tells the driver hey this is
important one like text me when you know
it's done then Gary uh Gary tan like
calls him he's like hey uh what is this
and he goes this is the thing I was
applying with this is instacart I just
went on my phone and I ordered you
groceries I ordered you a sixpack of
beer and one of our delivery guys
dropped it off and it's the same thing
that Jesse hitor was saying the other
day where he was like the difference
between a pitch and a Pres presentation
like the difference between the paper
pitch versus getting someone to feel the
experience um it's that same thing and
so Gary then emails the partners and
he's like at that point I think that
they called him back and they're like
hey I can't believe we're doing this
we're we've never let anyone in this
late but if you're interested we'd like
to have you and for YC that means YC
owns 7% of this own 7% of this company
that ended up being worth you know $6
billion dollar that one that one
decision which is also goes to show the
power of brand right like YY was not
trying they weren't it's not like they
hunted down instacart and had the genius
whatever it's that the founders wanted
that YC stamp that brand so badly that
they were willing to like jump through
hoops push through a no to get to a yes
and YY gets to make hundreds of millions
dollars off of it that's the power of
having a brand that people recognize and
care about and feel like is going to
help their odds of success yeah man
those guys have killed it and then Paul
Graham just effed off and lives in
England now in the woods writing poetry
and playing frisbee with this kids yeah
he he booked the win which nobody does
he's like cool I'm out of the race now
I'm going to go enjoy my
life not
allowed our software is the worst have
you heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better uh which
one you want to do yeah okay so I don't
even know really why this fascinates me
but it does
so this is a little primer for this uh
do you know what the Indian Hollywood is
called Bollywood Bollywood correct you
know that's the $100 question okay
here's the $200 question do you know
that in do you know that Bollywood is
the second biggest like kind of movie
industry in the world yes okay good
there you go that's a freebie now what
you don't know what you probably don't
know is that the that Bollywood is
famous people the famous people in
Bollywood are like the are the most
famous people on Earth aren't they it's
like George Clooney times 10 yeah
exactly so like shukan Ora Bashan these
guys are like Gods meaning if they get
the flu or they get sick there's
thousands of people standing outside
their building with candles like being
like take my health uh like you know you
can't die and the reason why is that the
stars in India it's not like so it's not
like George Clooney so George Clooney
will come onto the scene in his 20s but
he hasn't really made it yeah there 30s
he becomes a star and by his 40s he's
kind of on the way out he plays a couple
roles of old guys and he's done these
guys in India it's like you get picked
when you're 20 they're like you're the
star and the movie is going to make you
look like James Bond like you're you're
only cool everybody loves you and you're
the best and that's the role and then
people watch that movie like this guy's
the best then that same guy will be the
hero in movies for the next 30 to 40
years got it like he'll be 50 and he'll
be like he's the Big Man on Campus at
college and it's like what this guy's 50
and he's playing that role type of thing
and and like you know but the girl in
the movie will be in her 20s and he'll
be in his 40s or 50s but he's like the
the hero the stud and so don't don't
don't the movies even have intermissions
aren't they like three hour long movies
yeah yeah there's a halftime where you
go and like eat um it's pretty great
honestly that's a that's a that's
something that every movie should do um
the other thing about movies in India
all music in India comes from the movies
so every movie is a musical
that's weird and then every M every song
comes from a movie so so like there's no
like hit song that's not in the movies
it's like all one pie right so it's like
the center of culture okay so why does
that matter why am I telling you all
about this well because one thing has
really changed and once I realized that
I was like if that changed that's going
to cause a whole bunch of other changes
and here's the
change so most of these Indian stars
that I'm talking about when they're in
their 20s and their 30s
they look like your boy their body was a
little a little round it was it was a
little soft it was a normal person's
body and all of a sudden these guys
turned
50 and they're now absolutely shredded
every Jack City Jack City every single
movie star now like this guy run SN so
basically they're all jacked and they
all went from normal looking people
normal humans to 55y olds with 12 packs
and the so if you think about that
you're like okay whatever who cares
these guys discovered like testosterone
and HGH and like dieting and working out
cool but there's like a carryon effect
again these guys are Gods they're heroes
in India so now I met up with this uh
Sonia has a has a cousin who's like in
India this guy's 12 years old the last
time he came to visit America all he
cared about was like video games because
he's like oh I love playing video games
video games are amazing as any
10-year-old cares about and the second
thing he cared about was like going to
Target he's like oh Walmart can I go to
Walmart can I go to Target because he
had seen like you know Mr Beast giving
away $10,000 out of out of Walmart he's
like oh my God I can't wait to go that's
my dude R Sing looks like Wolverine yeah
exactly and if you go look at this guy
like five years ago or seven years ago
when he's like got his you know 10 years
ago when he got his break in movies like
did not look anything like this so
anyways now the guy came to visit and I
was like so like what's your favorite
video game now you want to go to Walmart
buddy and he's like no you have a gym
and I was like yeah but like you're a
kid what do you mean and he's like he
started going to the gym twice a day at
my house and all he wanted to talk about
was the gym and I was like huh I was
like oh of course like all the movie
stars got shredded that became the new
male ideal standard and so of course now
everybody there is on like a fitness
kick which made me think who's making
protein powder in India and so I went
deep on this and I started looking up I
I was like if if Fitness is now thing if
getting shredded is now the thing the
whole supplements and fitness industry
that we have here is going to translate
over there it's going to be rebuilt
overnight and it's going to be 10 times
bigger right India doesn't seem like a
supplement they don't seem like they
don't seem like a supplement culture as
of now until these guys if you go look
at these guys' Instagram profile and
they're like this is the my favorite
peanut butter I could eat that other
peanut butter and get fat but if I eat
this peanut butter I get fit sure enough
that they selling like hot cakes I
ordered some from India it just arrived
in like a giant styrofoam container um
and I was like and so now you see that
whole industry blowing up and I I would
love to I'm a little bit far away from
it right like I'm not like in the scene
so it's hard for me to participate but
I'm looking I'm on the hunt for finding
the right investment that is in the
Indian Fitness scene because it is a
necessary consequence of the movie stars
getting shredded anyways that's my
Indian food is if you had to make a
ranking of cuisine of one to diabetes of
like Cuisine that's set up to make you
look amazing naked uh Indian food would
not be at the top of that list you know
like maybe Mexican food like avocados
meat rice all right great you've heard
about the Mediterranean diet you've
never heard about the Bollywood diet
where's like the fried cheese and
coconut milk diet you know what I mean
like it's not exactly set up to like you
know like what is it naan and ghee is
that is that butter Rice C bread butter
and fried cheese like it's not it's not
entirely set up to make you look good in
the nude so that's good the Indians uh
maybe now they're going to understand
macros and they're going to stay in the
the need for protein exactly and I went
and I looked up the Indian Fitness
influencers on Instagram because I was
like oh there's going to be Fitness
influencers who are they these guys have
like 12 million 20 million followers
whereas like the same person in the US
market will have like 800,000 to a
million or two million just because
there so many more people and people in
India are like absolutely addicted to
the Facebook ecosystem of apps like
WhatsApp is everything the second best
thing to Whatsapp Instagram you know
like what's behind that Facebook and
like that's just like that's the
internet there you know and you know
that you've had some success India has
had some success in Olympics recently
the 4x4 the 4 the 4x400 meter dash with
uh India got like second or third at the
world championships the most recent gold
you joking or is that real it's real CA
because we used to have like a like a
Archer or something like that a shooter
that was like the only guy who was even
close to um um the guy who won the
Olympics and the world championships and
the javelin Indian guy wow uh and he
looks great he looks he looks like a he
looks like a like you want to look like
him been eating eating some of that
protein peanut butter no the uh Indians
are doing good in track and field lately
um and so and by like lately I mean like
last year and it's like the only time an
Indian has ever done half decent in
track if you look at soccer there's like
no Indian players you look at basketball
there's no Indian players there's like
none zero it's crazy I've never seen
like a 6'8 Indian no they exist trust me
billion people you're gonna the bell
curve like when you have a billion
people under the area of the bell curve
you're going to get you're going to get
people that are that are tall there's
one guy actually he's on the Kings uh
like development team Sim bullar he's 7
72 or something like that I've seen
Giants in from every country I don't
remember seeing a a a 6'8 Indian guy
with a 35 in vert I've never seen that
that I've never seen yes you're
correct um speaking of Indian things uh
our boy uh Anan from CB insights by the
way he came on here and we were just
talking about cap table he's only raised
I think eight or10 million there's a
rumor I told him I'm G to talk I go I'm
G to talk about this on the Pod but
don't tell me anything I'm just reading
this article that I read there's a rumor
that they're about to sell for $800
million um so our guest a
non pretty cool if they we on the pot I
remember we were like this thing's got
to be worth 300 400 million and he was
like you know non-committal about it but
I think he probably knew it was worth
more than that in the article it said
they're doing 80 million in Revenue so
10x Revenue 10x Revenue that would be
pretty amazing I mean I would I if I had
a bet I bet he owns half the company so
he would make many hundreds of millions
of dollars uh that would be huge and as
a reminder if people didn't see that
episode you should go cuz he's an idea
machine
so the episode we did with Anand is
awesome because he has like 50 startup
ideas that we went through and reacted
to as well as he tells the story of his
father passed away and his father owned
a chemical plant in India and he's
running CB insights a tech startup in in
America that's doing well and then he
just was like I have to deal with this
like my father passed away there's a
plant there's like a hundred people
working there and so he goes to India
and he learns how to run this plant
while running CV insights to employees I
think he stabilizes it gives and then
like created like some Equity plan or
whatever and then and then bounced but
really kind of Amazing Story do you
think that life do you think that life
for a non let's say he sells let's say
that he I he lives in New Jersey so
let's just say that he pays half in
taxes let's say that he owns half the
company so he makes $400 million let's
say that he walks away with 300 million
do you think that there's a difference
in life from 300 million and 50
million not really yeah I don't think so
either really you know I I would imagine
after 50 you can buy the jet instead of
rent the jet you know like what's the
difference what is he gonna do yeah I
don't think it matters no I what I will
say is like it's all relative to the
person so like you know Mike Tyson found
a way to spend 100 million dollars right
like you know people can find a way to
spend but then also Elon took you know a
couple hundred million bucks and used it
to fund his own crazy moonshot bets that
nobody else would do right so like for
Elon the difference between 50 and $ 250
or whatever million dollars was the
difference of Tesla and SpaceX existing
versus maybe they wouldn't have um or
surviving maybe they wouldn't have
because he was able to put the money in
so I guess to the right person yes but
for 99.9% of people no yeah I don't
think it makes any difference I chamath
had a good episode on uh on uh Allin and
he goes after 50 million it made zero
difference like I had that I could
acquire everything I wanted to at 50 and
anything else he was like it was like
stakes in basketball teams but that
means zero difference that's just like
in a business expense when um whenever I
hear stuff like this like when people
are like you know oh you know money
doesn't make you that happy or like you
know after this amount doesn't really do
anything for you it's like yeah you're
probably right but I'm just going to
check yeah I would like to find out I'd
like to find out I'm I'm gonna go ahead
and test for
myself I think that all the time as well
uh all we did this episode where someone
like asking me like what was it like uh
after making a little bit and I was like
it feels this way and this way but you
should go and figure it out on your own
you should you should you should double
check my math nval had a great thing
because like nval is like the like um
you know the wise uh guy in the in the
in the the tech and business ecosystem
and you would think that somebody who's
so wise and is like you know sort of
enlightened is going to just be like you
know what like uh it's not what matters
and he does say it's not the main thing
that matters he's like you know the real
goal is is um you know a strong mind a
strong body and a house full of love but
he's like you know nobody wants to hear
that and he goes the easiest way to
escape the rat race is just to win and
then let it then you can let it go if
that's far easier than trying to
convince you not to play and I was like
that is practical wisdom he's like it
won't make you significantly happier but
you're not going to believe me until you
do it yourself so go ahead and get after
it yeah
exactly yeah I love that practical
wisdom um you want to do any more of
these we we can do one more uh do you
want to do you want to do this
Metropolis thing or IMG well let's do
Metropolis so I don't know much I don't
know too much about this but I think
that it's pretty wild what did you see
so we both got interested I did a little
bit of research but basically there's a
startup that the the the the founder he
originally had a company called I think
Park me and it was just like an app that
told you where parking spot spots were
and he ended up selling it but it wasn't
n like a home run of a success I think
like they got their money back plus a
little bit something like that then he
goes on and he's like I did this all
wrong I have to think about this as an
investor and we have to like acquire
parking lots and we're going to create
technology that makes it easy so you
don't need to like uh you don't need to
scan in when you go and pay at a parking
lot we're just going to be able to track
your car
automatically he's been doing this for a
couple years and he just bought a
parking lot like a a company that owns a
bunch of parking lots for $1.1 billion
dollar and I saw that and I was like all
right what the hell is going on here
yeah the same thing caught my eye the
guy made like a there's like a billion
dollar acquisition or something like
that what I thought was the story is
that so there's this one blueprint of
business that's a very good blueprint
this is the blueprint that constellation
software uses which is vertical SAS what
is vertical SAS vertical SAS is how um
oh there's a you know every Golf Club in
the country needs some golf club booking
management system system so people can
book their T tea times and then they can
rent their clubs and then they can you
know have a membership and whatever and
there's some person out there that made
some software sold it to some golf clubs
and what a company like constellation
will do is they're like perfect because
that software is not going to be like
you know Microsoft is not going to go
compete in that market Facebook and
Google are not going to go compete in
that market honestly nobody really is
going to compete in this market and if
there are if there is someone it's it's
kind of so fragmented that as they start
to get momentum they get to one23
million of annual revenue we'll just buy
them and then we'll own all of the golf
club software systems uh or sorry golf
uh like golf uh what what do you call
them like the members club or whatever
whatever it's called um but basically
vertical sass software and so same thing
for dentists and same thing for um
whatever rent you know industrial
rentals or whatever so vertical SAS has
been a very very lucrative play
especially if you roll them up so have
you been to Constellation website by the
way uh not they like give you like they
give you like five categories of like
businesses they own you click on like
all right this this one of five and then
they give you like a list of 10 you
click on one of the 10 but it's they own
so many businesses that they're
basically linking to other companies
that own other companies meaning like we
own this holding company which owns
holding companies in these five
categories and you have to click through
four different websites to actually see
the name of a company so they must own
hundreds or even thousands of small
software businesses it has acquired over
500 businesses since being founded um
they I think they make offers to like
hundreds of soft hundreds of companies
every year if not a thousand companies a
year or something like that to to give
an example so Jonas Jonas is one of
these five they have six groups so six
groups Jonas is one of the groups and it
says they do Hospitality clubs and
Resorts spas and fitness construction
payments Moving and Storage you click it
it says so you go to Jonas Software and
it says we're a family of vertical
Market software companies and then they
own 140 just under the Jonas
umbrella it's crazy right in 40
different
markets it's crazy it's it's a it's a
really wild setup they have and uh if
you haven't ever gone and read uh Mark
Leonard's letters uh definitely like you
know worth a worth that's like getting
an MBA go go through and read all of his
annual letters you know uh for the last
like 25 years or whatever very
interesting guy very interesting company
we've talked about consolation before
but what's interesting is I thought like
it seemed like that was the blueprint
you just buy vertical SAS companies and
you roll them up what those parking guys
doing is basically took the vertical SAS
and then was like cool let's just own
all the lots too let's make a vertical
company that's not just SAS it's got SAS
on the top but underneath it is the real
estate and the the actual like um you
know the brick and mortar underneath so
that we can um like forget trying to
sell our software to these guys and try
to convince these old school parking
operators that they should use our thing
because it's more efficient we'll just
buy it from them in the inefficient
State and then use our software to make
it more efficient and um so it seems
like a pretty big bet if I understood it
correctly but honestly I didn't do a ton
of research just what I understood from
the Tweet they paid 1.7 billion for a
company that owns parking
lots yeah it's a lot impressive that's
huge right yeah um all right uh do we
want to wrap there yeah let's wrap it up
all right that's a
[Music]
pot